NINETEENTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
SEVEN BILLS TO CONSIDER THIS
MORNING BEFORE WE BEGIN I HAVE
A FEW HOUSEKEEPING NOTES TO
COVER FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS- CHRIS HOLDEN
AND THREE OF US FOR COVERING
VACANCIES ON THE COMMITTEE
TODAY- JUST TO BE CLEAR WE ARE
STILL IN MASK WEARING SOCIAL
DISTANCE SEEN WEARING RULES AND
SO IF YOU'RE INSIDE THE
CHAMBERS I SEE WE HAVE A COUPLE
PEOPLE TODAY YOU START TO
SOCIALLY DISTANCE WEAR MASK
EVEN IF YOU'RE SPEAKING- AND
ENSURE THAT YOU'RE BITING BY
ALL OF OUR RULES IF. YOU ARE
NOT ABIDING BY RULES EITHER IN
THE GALLERY OR ON THE PHONE WE
WILL ASK YOU TO DISCONTINUE
YOUR PARTICIPATION IN THIS
MEETING- SO WE ASK THAT YOU
SIMPLY ABIDE BY OUR RULES. WHEN
A BILL COMES UP WE WILL ALLOW
IF THERE WAS A PREDETERMINED
WITNESS FOR THE WITNESS TO
SPEAK FIRST IN SUPPORT. A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION IF IT HAD
BEEN- GIVEN TO US AFTER THAT WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES AND
WE WILL ASK PEOPLE FOR
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION WE EXPECT
THEM TO SAY THEIR NAME. THEIR
POSITION- AND IF THEY REPRESENT
AN ORGANIZATION THAT'S FINE.
BUT THAT'S IT NO MORE
DISCUSSION AFTER THAT- ONLY THE
WITNESSES ARE GIVING FULL
DISCUSSION THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE SO WE EXPECT ALL. OF
THE PRESENTATIONS- AND THE-
WITNESSES TO DEAL WITH THE
FISCAL ANALYSIS IF YOU'RE FINE
WITH THE FISCAL ANALYSIS YOU
JUST ASK FOR THE BILL TO MOVE-
WE WILL. COMPLETE START I
BELIEVE AS A SUB COMMITTEE IS
WERE WAITING FOR QUORUM. WE
NEED ONE MORE. ALL. MISTER.
MISS I DON'T KNOW WHO'S CALLING
REMEMBER. YEAH I'M SECRETARY
LIFE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GONZALEZ PRESIDENT BIGELOW
CALDERON. CARILLO TELL DOLLY
DAVIES ON APRIL I WATER GARCIA
LIVING QUIRK ROBERT RIVAS WEBER.
HOLDEN VACANCY GOVERNMENT
CONCEIVED HOLDEN THREE OF US.
VACANCY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE CALL MIND TODAY FOR
TESTIMONY IS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR
TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN.
CONFIRMATIONS ALSO AVAILABLE ON
THE DAILY FILE AND ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE IF YOU HAVE
ANY PROBLEMS YOU CAN CALL OUR
OFFICE AT SIX AT. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO EIGHT
ONE. AND MY STAFF CAN TRY TO
HELP YOU WE ALSO ALWAYS ACCEPT
TESTIMONY OR POSITIONS- BY
EMAIL OR TRADITIONAL MAIL- AND-
IF FOR SOME REASON YOU DON'T
GET THROUGH TODAY OR YOU HAVE
PROBLEMS OR WANT TO EXPAND ON
YOUR TESTIMONY YOU CAN ALWAYS
PROVIDE US WITH THAT. ALL RIGHT
TODAY WE ARE GOING TO START
WITH. IT LOOKS LIKE MISTER
BLOOM AB THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
I HAVE. I'M SURE MOTION DIVIDE
DR QUIRK IN A SECOND BY MISTER
CALDERON MISTER BLOOM YOU HAND.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CURRENTLY
OF A JURISDICTION DOES NOT
ADOPT A HOUSING ELEMENT BY THE
STATUTORY DEADLINE IT MUST
ADOPT A REVISED HOUSING ELEMENT
EVERY FOUR YEARS RATHER THAN
EVERY EIGHT THIS PENALTY FOR
NON COMPLIANCE WITH HOUSING
ELEMENT ADOPTION DEADLINES HAS
PROVEN. INEFFECTIVE AND LED TO
SOME UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SO
AB THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT
ADDRESSES THESE PROBLEMS BY
CLARIFYING THE LAW TO REQUIRE
ADOPTION OF AN H. C. D.
APPROVED HOUSING ELEMENT BY THE
STATUTORY DEADLINE. THE BILL
EMANATES THE FOR YOUR PENALTY
AND INSTEAD PROVIDES THAT
FAILURE TO ADOPT ON TIME
OBLIGATES THE JURISDICTIONS TO
COMPLETE ANY NECESSARY RESOUNDS
WITH ONE WITHIN ONE YEAR RATHER
THAN IN THREE YEARS ALLOWED FOR
JURISDICTIONS THAT ADOPT ON
TIME. THANK YOU I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND- MY WITNESSES
BRIAN AUGUSTA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONES TO HEAR FROM OUR WITNESS
BRIAN AUGUSTA. MORE INJURED
MEMBERS BRIAN GOT- ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT APPRECIATE
TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION THE
CHAIR. AND- CAN I VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OPERATOR WE CAN
GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB.
THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE. TO BE
CLEAR. THAT WAS THIRTEEN NINETY
EIGHT CORRECT. THIRTEEN NINETY
EIGHT. N. I CAN WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE GALLERY. IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK I SEEN
NOBODY I SEE NOBODY ON THE
SCREENS FROM THE REMOTE STATION
WHICH I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S UP
TODAY. NO NO OKAY. WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE COMMENT IN THE QUEUE
OKAY THAT'LL WORK. IT JUST A
BRIEF MOMENT PRESS TOGETHER THE
LINE NUMBER.
NINE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY THIS IS REGARDING
P. FIVE THREE SEVEN NO I'M
SORRY IT'S AB. THIRTEEN NINETY
EIGHT. OKAY THANK YOUNG TECH
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT MISTER
BLOOM- IT IS OUR MOTION SECOND.
UNLESS THERE'S MORE YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SAY WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL AND I'M DISPENSED WITH HIS
WE GET ANOTHER DEMOCRAT HERE
THANK YOU. NEXT MISS BURKE. AT
FOURTEEN OH SEVEN ENJOY THE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISCREANT A SECOND BY
DOCTOR QUIRK. BEING HUMAN THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN AB SEVEN
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION IS A MEASURE
DESIGNED TO EDUCATE OUR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS ON THE IMPACT OF
IMPLICIT BIAS IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM IN ORDER TO BRING
DISPARITIES AND NEGATIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES TO AN END. I IN OF
THAT THE PRESENCE OF IMPLICIT
BIAS IN OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
LEADS TO DIFFERENCES IN THE
QUALITY OF CARE GIVEN TO
PATIENTS AND THEIR OVERALL
HEALTH OUTCOMES ANANNUAL COST
OF SIXTY THOUSAND FOR THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING TO AUDIT
LICENSING FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN IMPLICIT
BUYING COURSE IMPLICIT BIAS
COURSES IS A SMALL PRICE TO PAY
TO INSURE THAT AWARENESS IS
BROUGHT TO THESE ISSUES. AND
SUPPORT OVER THE PHONE IS KURT
CURTIS LAYING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU I'M MISTER KING OF A
WITNESS ON THE LINE IT LOOKS
LIKE CURTIS LANE FROM THE-
ALLEGEDLY. IT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS YEP
I'M TRANSPLANT THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION PROF BOXES
OF AB FOURTEEN OH SEVEN.
OBVIOUSLY FOR COMMITTEE OFFICE
THE FISCAL. THIS BILL OF MINE.
IN THIS BILL AND NO OPPOSITE.
ACCORDING ME RUIZ WE FOR YOUR
I. GLOBAL THIS BILL. TO ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. AS NOBODY IN
THE GALLERY RISING TO SPEAK
WITH THE WE GO AHEAD AND TAKE
IT TO THE PHONE LINE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR AB FORTINO SEVEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAI AND IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB FORTINO SEVEN
YOU MADE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE SEVENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WARNING ADAM TURN
MEMBERS GREGORY ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT OF AB FORTINOS THANK
YOU. ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT. NINE
NINE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING THAT
I'M CHAIR AND MEMBERS WHEN
LOOKING BACK ON OF THE BLACK
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS JENNIFER KENNEDY
SPEAKING INDIVIDUALLY- IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO
COMMENTS. EXCEPT THAT IS YOUR
CLOSE MISS BURKE THANK YOU BACK
IT'S OUT WITH THE REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING EXCEPT MISS DOLLY
AND MISS DAVIES BUT BY THINK.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE. MISTER
MATHIS. AB SEVEN FIFTY FOR THE
CHAIR DOES NOT HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS BILL.
IT'S MADE BY MR BIGELOW. SECOND
BY MISTAKE PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR SIMPLY ALLOWS
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES TO GRANT A ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAY
EXTENSION FOR SIGMA IF THEY SO
CHOOSE ACCORDING TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS ANALYSIS THIS
WILL HAVE NIGEL COST TO DO IT
E. W. R. WITH THAT MEMBERS I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN ON THE
PHONES TODAY AS OUR PRIMARY
WITNESS IS SID NAG FROM RC RC
WHO CAN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IF
YOU HAVE. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
YOUR WITNESS ON THE PHONE SAID
KNACK. THE WITNESS THERE. YOUR.
OPERATORS ARE WITNESS. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. I DON'T SEE THAT
LINE AS BEING PART OF OUR OWN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WITHOUT A WITNESS THERE I SEE
NOBODY IN THE GALLERY RISING TO
SPEAK WILL GO TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB. SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR. AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN I'M
SORRY NINE TWENTY FIVE IF YOU
COULD PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE
THERE YOU ARE. NINE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WILL MOVE ON TO NINE
SEVENTY NINE SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN- GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WILLIAM
NOTHING BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
A RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO FURTHER. I'M
SORRY WE DO HAVE LINE TWENTY
FIVE LINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR THE NUMBERS MONEY
TO SIT BACK WITH BILL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
ALL JOBS FOR. THE TECHNICAL.
ARE COUNTY NEXT THE FED IMPACT
ON THIS BILL. AND WE THEREFORE
DO NOT EXPECT THE REQUEST ANY
FUNDS FROM THE STATE JUST PLAN
AFTER. USED TO BE TO SPELL.
ANYTHING THE ABILITY FOR TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THEIR STANDARD
BILL PLAN ARE DOWN RIGHT BEFORE-
SUBMITTING FIFTY R. R. .COM BUT
COMMITTING TO BEAT UP HEART THE
MOBILE OFF. THE RE OPENING BY
AND I'M SORRY THIS IS A I'M
TIME SPEAK THIS IS THE SUPPORT
OP. UNLESS WERE YOU THE WHAT
THIS WAS A LIVE WHAT. ARE WHAT
OKAY I WAS. I'M SORRY I. DON'T
WANT TO YOU MAY PROCEED SORRY.
OUR DETERMINATION WITH THE
COUNTY OR TO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE IN THE- POST
MEASURES ONE WE APPRECIATE DR
CLINTON'S- ADVANCEMENT TODAY
WITH. UNPAYABLE COSTS WILL
PUBLIC RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
THE COURT THANK YOU JACK. OKAY
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COLORS IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO SEVEN AB. SEVEN FIFTY FOUR.
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. I'M SAYING NO
COMMENTS MISTER ABBAS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AGAIN MEMBERS WITH
CALVIN WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF PUSH
BACKS IN A LOT OF THINGS WHERE-
COMMUNITIES WERE ABLE TO GET
TOGETHER AND DO THE PROCESSES
HOW THEY NORMALLY WOULD BE.
ESPECIALLY IN OUR RURAL AREAS
THAT LACK THE TECHNICAL SUPPORT
THIS BILL. AGAIN IS JUST AN
OPTIONAL ITEM IF YOU W. ARE SO
CHOOSES TO GIVE IT. AND THE
COST IS. MANAGEABLE AS STATED
IN THE ANALYSIS MEMBERS I ASK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE BILL GETS OUT. ON A ROLL
CALL WITH MR LEVINE VOTING NO
AND DR WEBBER AND THE CHAIR NOT
VOTING. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT UP DOCTOR ARAMBULA. YOU
HAVE AB. FIVE FIVE NINE THAT'S
THE AREA CODE FOR YOUR- AREA.
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OF A- MOTION BY
MISS CREE- A SECOND BY DOCTOR
CORK YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB FIVE
FIVE NINE WILL ADD NEW AND
UNDER REPRESENTED VOICES TO THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY
BOARD INCLUDING ONE OF THE
FIRST TRIBAL NATION SEATS
ACROSS ALL CONSERVANCY. AB FIVE
FIVE NINE ALSO REFRAINS THE
FOCUS OF COUNTY RESIDENT SEATS
INSURERS THAT THE BOARD IS
FULLY SEATED AND MAKES OTHER
CHANGES TO ALIGN THE OPERATION
AS A STATE AGENCY ALONGSIDE
OTHER CONSERVANCY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON AB FIVE FIVE NINE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE I THINK
YOU HAVE A WITNESS SHARON
WEAVER ON THE LINE WE WILL GO
TO YOUR WITNESS. GOOD MORNING
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. THANK YOU
SHARON WEAVER WITH THE FAMILY
HE MET RIVER PARKWAY AND
CONSERVATION TRUST WE REALLY
APPRECIATE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR
JOAQUIN ARAMBULA STILL WHICH IS
THAT AIM TO MAKE SOME POSITIVE
CHANGES IN THE CONSERVANCY
BOARD AND- CREATES BETTER
REPRESENTATION FOR EVERYBODY
AND IN THE VALLEY AND
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AND WINE
WITH THE IMPORTANT AT. THE FAN
JOAQUIN RIVER AS A FEW Y.
THREE. SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO A
BILL TANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU THAT IS THE WHEN AS WE HAVE
A WITH THAT I NOBODY RISE AND
THE GAL TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL
SO WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE ANY IN
SUPPORT OR- JUST YOUR NAME AND
YOUR- AND WE WERE. ON A. FIVE
NINE. AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
FIVE FIVE NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND ONE
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST TIME THANK
YOU. FIFTEEN POINT EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING IT'S PAUL YOUR ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN FRESNO AND
MADERA COUNTIES STILL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING-
MY NAME IS BOOKSELLING MARTINEZ
CALLING ON BEHALF OF BIRTH
NOBODY NEEDLES IN FRESNO IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY FIVE
NINETY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SARAH HUTCHINSON IN A
LONG TIME FOREVER RESIDENTS
HAVEFRESNO AND I STRONGLY URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON AB FIVE NINE.
THANK YOUNG. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN THE QUEUE. WONDERFUL
THANK YOU WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANYONE WANT TO
SPEAK ON IT NOW WITH THAT WE
LIKE TO CLOSER YOU TAKE THAT AS
YOUR CLOTHES STOPPED ARAMBULA I
THINK THAT IS MY CLOTHES
WONDERFUL THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL THANK YOU DOCTOR
AMBULANCE I WANT TO KNOW THAT
AB THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT FIVE
MISTER BLOOM GETS OUT ON THE B.
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER KING
HENRY UP. UP NOW SORRY. MR
BURNER HARBATH HERE I CAN'T
SEE- IN THAT CASE MISS BALCONY
IN YOUR NEXT. AB. NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT- THIS IS- I SEE YOUR
TESTIFYING ON A BILL THAT IS
BEING MOVED TO SUSPENSE. I
DON'T SEEM TO HAVE A NUMBER FOR
IT. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT IT IS AB
NINETY I'M SORRY IT'S AB NINE
EIGHT EIGHT THAT WE REST MAYBE
NINETY IMPROVE. ALL RIGHT THIS
THIS BILL IS- MOVING TO THE
SUSPENSE COUNTER SO THERE'S NO
MOTION NECESSARY. YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL ENGAGEMENT ON THE
BILL. THE FEDERALLY MANDATED
NINE EIGHTY IS COMING TO
CALIFORNIA IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWO A DEDICATED PHONE LINE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS IS OVERDUE
IN CRITICAL BUT THE TIMELINE
SET BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ALSO MAKES IT IMPERATIVE THAT
WE PASSED THE BILL. SO THAT WE
HAVE THE FUNDS AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THE
ANTICIPATED 30% INCREASE IN
CALL VOLUME AND CALIFORNIA'S
EMERGENCY MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
RESPONSE SYSTEM. THEN I NEED A
USER FEE IS CRITICAL TO FUNDING
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A
WORKING A COMPREHENSIVE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS SYSTEM. HOWEVER I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THE
NINETY DAY USER FEE REVENUE
WILL BE USED TO SUPPLEMENT AND
NOT SUPPLANT. CURRENT MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDING. I'VE BEEN
ENGAGING WITH STAKEHOLDERS%
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ON HOW TO
STRUCTURE THE NINE EIGHT USER
FEE. TO ENSURE THAT IT FUNDS
CRITICAL ELEMENTS OF THE NINE
EIGHT EIGHT SYSTEM. BUT IS
BALANCED THROUGH APPROPRIATE
CHECKS TO THAT END WE'VE
AMENDED THE BILL TWO OUT TO CAP
AT THE SAME LEVEL OF THE NINE
ONE ONE SURCHARGE EIGHTY CENTS.
AND FURTHER SPECIFIED THAT THE
NINETY USER FEE WILL BE SAID AT
THE SAME RATE AS NINE ONE ONE.
FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS
THEREFORE IT AND THEIR AFTER IT
WILL BE A RATE SET BY- YES
BASED ON ACTUAL COST APPROVED
BY THE LEGISLATURE. WE ADDED A
STRONG STATE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS
REQUIRING COUNTIES AND CALL
CENTERS REPORT ON THEIR
EXPENDITURES. THIS AMENDMENT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE EXISTING
LANGUAGE REQUIRING THE
LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE THE
ANNUAL RATE WILL ENSURE THE
NINETY THAT USER FEE IS NOT A
BLANK CHECK. WE HAVE TIED THE
PERMITTED EXPENDITURES TO THE
FEDERAL AUTHORIZING STATUTE
WHICH WILL ENSURE THE REVENUE
IS ONLY SPENT ON I NEED A CALL
CENTERS. AND THE SERVICES THAT
ARE A DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE
NINETY DAY CALLS. WE'VE ADDED
PRIORITIZATION. WERE REVENUE
WILL FIRST AND FOREMOST FUND
THE NINETY DAY CALL CENTERS.
FOLLOWED BY MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS
FOLLOWED BY ANY OTHER ELIGIBLE
EXPENDITURES UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
WE'VE ALSO MADE A TECHNICAL
CHANGE TO ENSURE THAT LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT
PAYING THIS USER FEE. I WILL
ALSO NOTE THAT WE TOOK MANY OF
CABLES PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
INCLUDING ADDING THE KEY CAP
ADDING LIMITED LIABILITY
PROVISIONS FOR SERVICE
CARRIERS. AND REMOVING THE
EXEMPTION FOR PREPAID LINES. I
WANT TO KNOW THAT WE DO
ANTICIPATE SIGNIFICANT COST
SAVINGS IN THE SYSTEM FROM THE
PROGRAM WHERE PROGRAM SIMILAR
TO NINETY EIGHT ALREADY EXISTS
THE COST SAVINGS HAVE BEEN IN
THE TENS OF MILLIONS. SAVINGS
FROM REDUCTIONS IN AMBULANCE
RIDES EMERGENCY ROOM TREATMENT
AND TO DECREASE AND POLICE
RESPONSE TO MENTAL HEALTH
CALLS. JUST ONE EXAMPLE IN
EUGENE OREGON WHICH OBVIOUSLY
PALES IN COMPARISON TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY SPENT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS ON THEIR
COMPUTER PROGRAM BUT SAVED
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
YEAR THAT'S A RETURN ON
INVESTMENT OF SEVEN DOLLARS FOR
EVERY ONE DOLLAR SPENT. HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK ON THE BILL IS
ANGELA CAMPBELL FOR THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM MENTAL ILLNESS
AND TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. IS TARA CAN BOECE
MEN FROM THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
YOUR- YOUR WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE AND THEY GET TWO MINUTES
TO TALK WITH FISCAL IMPACT OF
THE BILL WE'LL START WITH
ANGELA. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ANGELA CAMPBELL AND I IN THE
NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY
AND PUBLIC POLICY NOT MEET THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS. YOUR CONGRESS PASSED
THE NATIONAL SUICIDE HOTLINE
DESIGNATION ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY WHICH DESIGNATED NINETY
DAY IF THE NATION WIDE MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUICIDE CRISIS LINE.
CONGRESS RECOGNIZED THAT THE
NUMBER IS NOT ENOUGH. AND
EXPLICITLY DESIGNED THE STATE
NINETY EIGHT USER FEES TO
PROVIDE A SUSTAINABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT THE
COURT THE NINE MEETING SYSTEM
IS ALWAYS PROTECTED. FROM GOING
TO CREATE A TRUE ALTERNATIVE TO
NINE ONE ONE. IF WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THE MOST CRITICAL
PIECES OF THE NINETY TRUMP. ARE
FUNDED. IN NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE ALLOW US TO LINK
ARGUMENT THINKING REGENCY
RESPONSE SYSTEM AND LEVERAGE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
INVESTMENT. TO EXPAND AND
IMPROVE THE SYSTEM COULD TRULY
DELIVER A MENTAL HEALTH
RESPONSE THE NUMBER OF CRISES.
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
ASSEMBLY SUPPORT NFL CONGRESS'S
INTENT FOR A. B. NINE EIGHT
EIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE'LL GO NOW. TO TERRA GAMBLE
EASTMAN. GOOD MORNING SHARE AND
MY- TRYING ABOUT LOOK AT IN TO
WORKERS AREN'T THERE AND STRONG
FOR EACH HAPPENING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THEY CAN MIGHT
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
WITHOUT WILL GO TO THE FOR
LINES IS ANY- I SEE NOBODY IN
THE- I'M SORRY STILL NOT TO
PEOPLE BEING THE GALLERY
BESIDES CHRIS. SO FORGIVE ME I
WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER YOU AT
SOME POINT I'M SEE NOBODY
RISING TO SPEAK IN THE GALLERY
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
TO A. B. NINE EIGHT EIGHT.
THANK YOU MAY CHAIR AND A YOU
RICHEST INTO OF THE OF A NINE
EIGHT EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THE TIME AND
MINE SO EIGHT YOUR IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OFF WHAT'S ABOUT. LINE ON BUT
ILLNESS ALSO KNOWN AS NOBBY CAL.
AND SUPPORT THANKS. NINE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MORE RED HAWK
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS CALLS FOR
US WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD MINUS OF. AND
MOVING ON TO LINE ONE THIRTEEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ADRIN SHELTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES IN THE
SUPPORT THANK. NINE TWENTY ONE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF NAMI CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORTER. NINE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. NINE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THIRTY SEVEN YOU
MAY BE I MEAN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THAT
ENSURE MEMBERS MY NAME IS TOWN
HALL. AND WE ARE WITH THE MILD
POTTSTOWN SHIN COAST. BONKERS
AND WE ARE AS A STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND PART OF AB NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU. NINE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING HEIDI
STRUGGLE REPRESENTING THE
MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
WELL AS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH EMPOWERMENT
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DR GREEN MACINTOSH
BACO WITH THE FACT MY BELLY
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AS THE MOBILEYE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH COALITION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE VOTE YES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DUSTIN
WHETHER BE IT THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED IT'S
NINE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK THEM. NINE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS SAM BRENT CAN I USE THAN
THEM OF MY PROGRAM HI-
REPRESENT THE TREVOR PROJECT
AND WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB. NINE EIGHT EIGHT. NINE
ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
BURNING A ROCKET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE ASSOCIATION
UNFORTUNATELY RECENT AMENDMENTS
DO NOT ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS WE
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THE HOMELESS
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO OUT. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE GOOD MORNING
AGAIN THIS FALL YOU ON BEHALF
OF SOUND HOUSE THE STATUS SAY
K. AND THE CALIFRNIA WHICH AND
SO. ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOUNG AND ONE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD- MORE MY CHAIR AND
THEN HI BENDING THE COUNTY TO
HAVE A HIGH DIRECTIVE SAYS YEAH
WITH THE- OF AMENDED AB NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT AND CHRIS CONNOR.
EIGHT ON THE BALLOT THANK YOU.
NINE ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THANK COMING UP WITH
THE L. A. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
MORNING THIS IS TRACY ROSENBERG
CALLING ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND
PRIVACY AND SUPPORT OF AB NINE
EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JOHN THE TEHRAN
DIRECTOR FOR VALLEY BEACH OTHER
CRAP IN OPPOSITION AB. THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE
DOCTOR COURT HAS A QUESTION.
YES MADAM ASSEMBLY MEMBER- I'M-
JUST NOT QUITE UNDERSTANDING IT
SAYS WELL THE FIRST TWO YEARS
IT'S THE SAME AS THE NINE ONE
ONE FEE. WHICH ALSO SHOULD GIVE
YOU A BALANCE BECAUSE THE
COSTS. ARE GOING TO BE LESS
THAN- THAT IS COLLECTED BY THE
NINE ONE ONE FEE. AND THEN
AFTER THAT YOU'RE GOING TO USE
THE NINE ONE ONE APPROACH. TO
CALCULATE THE COSTS- I'M- AND
I'M NOT QUITE SURE HOW THAT
WORKS BECAUSE FOR NINE ONE ONE
YOU'RE JUST LOOKING AT THE CALL
CENTERS. BUT HERE YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE CALL CENTERS
PLUS- SOME O THE DUTIES
CARRIED OUT AS A RESULT OF
CALLS THAT COME IN- SO HOW CAN
YOU BE USING THE SAME
APPROACHES NINE ONE ONE. WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT MORE COSTS
THAN THAT. THANK YOU MISTER
CARTER QUESTION- FIRST I'LL
NOTE THAT THAT THE AMENDMENT
THAT WE TAKE IN THIS COMMITTEE
AT THE RECOMMENDATION OF- THE
COMMITTEE WAS TO BACK. TO SET
THAT FEE FOR THE FIRST TWO
YEARS SO THAT WE HAVE CERTAINTY
ABOUT WHAT THOSE SET UP COSTS
WILL BE AND IT WILL START ABOUT
SIX AS I MENTIONED THE PHONE
WILL START RINGING CALIFORNIA
JULY TWENTY TWENTY TWO NO
MATTER WHAT WE DO. AND SO AND
WE ARE- WE ARE- WE ARE SETTING
THOSE FEES AND MAKING SURE THAT
WORK WE'RE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT IT
IS BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ONLY CHARGING ACTUAL
COST SO- YES WILL BE CHARGED
WITH FIGURE OUT ACTUAL CLASSES
COMING TO LEGISLATURE IN
GETTING THE APPROVAL OF THE I'M-
OF THE LEGISLATURE ON NOT FEE.
ALTHOUGH WE'RE OPEN TO. YOU
KNOW HOW WE DO THIS IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE SURE
THERE'S CLARITY AND STRONG
GUARDRAILS WHICH AS I MENTIONED
THE BEGINNING OR MANY OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING TAKEN
CURRENTLY- SO. I AM NOT. I WANT
TO BE CLEAR DR COURT BEFORE
THIS EXCHANGE CONTINUES BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO BE
CONFUSED THERE ARE NO
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
THIS BILL IS ON SUSPENSE. IT
WILL EITHER LEAVE SUSPENSE WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS OR COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS BUT NOTHING AT THIS
POINT YOU CAN'T TAKE
AMENDMENTS. WILD BILL IS ON
SUSPENSE SO. THERE WAS BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN PROBABLY THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE MEMBER
STAFF ABOUT POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS
HAVE ONE BE VERY CLEAR. THIS
BILL HAS NOT YET BEEN AMENDED
IF IT WILL BE AMENDED ILL BE
AMENDED. IF IT SHOULD COME OFF
OF SUSPENSE IN IT COULD BE A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT AMENDMENT
YES AND I APOLOGIZE I SHOULD
SAY THAT WE TOOK AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS. AND THEY WENT IN
THROUGH COUNCIL THAT ARE IN
PRINCE I SHOULD SAY- AGAIN DO
THAT BACK AND FORTH THAT ARE
NOT BEING DONE. BY THE KICK I
GUESS THAT WAS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS I SHOULD CLEAR.
POLITICS FOR BETTER STAY THERE
IN THIS COMMITTEE THEIR
REQUESTED AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
THEY ARE NOT AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
UNTIL WE ACTUALLY APPROVE THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND THEY GET MOVED
TO THE FLOOR. YEAH THANK YOU
I'M SO I'M SORRY IT'S JUST
PERCENT ALL AND I DON'T WANT
EVERYBODY RUNNING TO ME WITH
WONDER. WHY I WANT AMEND THEIR
BILL AND SUSPENSE I APOLOGIZE
AND I'M SORRY I MISSPOKE
MANAGER. IT'S OKAY. IT IS
TOTALLY DIFFERENT FROM THE NINE
ONE ONE FEE BECAUSE YOU'RE-
YOU'RE DOING BOTH CALL CENTERS
AND THE WORK SO I DON'T SEE HOW
YOU CAN SAY IT'S BASED ON THE
NINE ONE ONE THREE- I'M SORRY
IF YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
QUESTION. THAT'S FINE SO IT
DOES COVER A DIFFERENT SCOPE OF
THINGS WHICH I THINK IS WHAT
YOU'RE GETTING AT IS THAT RIGHT
YES SO AND THAT WILL BE BUT-
YES HAS THE AUTHORITY SO COUPLE
THINGS IMPORTANT THAT IS THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL BE
REIMBURSING 85% OF THE COST OF
THE MOBILE CRISIS RESPONSE
TEAM. THERE FEDERAL LEGISLATION
SO THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE
COSTS WILL KNOCK HIM DOWN TO
THE STATE THE FIA COUNTIES- BUT
WE WILL BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THE
AMOUNT OF. PERCENT OF CALLS WE
EXPECT TO HAVE THOSE RESPONSE
TEAMS THE COST OF THOSE
RESPONSE TEAMS WHAT THE
REMAINING 15% IS AND WORK THAT
INTO THE ESTIMATE THAT WILL
COME TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
APPROVAL IF I MAKE SENSE. OKAY
COME CLOSE ENOUGH THANKS. VERY
MISTER KIRK MADE IN UNDERSTAND.
CLOSE THANK YOU AND I APOLOGIZE
AGAIN FOR THE LACK OF CLARITY
ON MY PART MADAM CHAIR. AND BUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THIS
BILL BE MOVED OFF SUSPEND.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE WILL
MOVE ON TO- MISS BERNARD
HORNBACH. MISTER.
HORVATH HAS.
ANNOUNCEMENTS ON SCHOOL AND-
STATE LANDS ARE LANDS GRANTED
FOR A TO THE STATE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO GENERATE
REVENUES FOR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
UNDER THE SCHOOL AND BREAK ACT
THE COMMISSION IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR TAKING ALL ACTIONS
NECESSARY. TO DEVELOP SCHOOL
LANDS INTO PERMANENT A
PRODUCTIVE REVENUE SOURCES. THE
SCHOOL LANDS ARE DIFFICULT TO
MANAGE BECAUSE THEY'RE BROKEN
UP INTO NONCONTIGUOUS SQUARE
MILE PARCELS THE LEGISLATURE
FROM THE CONSULTING THE SCHOOL
IMPARTIAL CENTER CONTIGUOUS
HOLDINGS IS ESSENTIAL. TO SOUND
AND EFFECTIVE MANAGEMENT AS
SUCH EXISTING LAW AUTHORIZES
THE COMMISSION TO SELL ISOLATED
NON ECONOMIC SCHOOL LANDS. AND
USE THE FUNDS FOR THE SALES TO
PURCHASE REAL PROPERTY THAT
WILL GENERATE ADDITIONAL
REVENUES. THE PROBLEM UNDER
EXISTING LAW IS THAT THE
COMMISSION IS CONSTRAINED BY
THE EXISTING 5% CAP FOR THE USE
OF FUNDS TO PAY ANCILLARY COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH LAND PERSON
PURCHASES. AND THE EXISTING CAP
UNDERMINES THE COMMISSION'S
COMPETITIVENESS IN THE MARKET
BECAUSE IT MUST RELY ON SELLERS
TO VOLUNTEER MOMENTARILY. TO
PAY THE COSTS THAT EXCEED THE
5% CAP WELL OTHER PURCHASERS
MAY BE WILLING TO PAY ALL
COSTS. IN ADDITION IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHAT THIRD PARTY COSTS
ARE FOR SPECIFIC SEAL AND THE
COMMISSION CANNOT. MAKE A DOWN
PAYMENT ON LAND PURCHASED ON A
TIMELY FASHION BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO
SO. AB THIRTEEN NINETY
CLARIFIES THE COMMISSION
CAMPAIGN BETWEEN LAND
ACQUISITION COSTS. AND REMOVES
THE 5% CAP ON THESE EXPENSES.
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES THAT THE
COMMISSION MORE FLEXIBILITY
WHEN IT SELLS OR CONVEYS LANDS
IN A MANNER THAT RESULTS IN
RETURNING ANCESTRAL LANDS. TO
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO BETTER POSITION
THE COMMISSION TO AVAIL ITSELF
OF OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO
FACILITATE RENEWABLE ENERGY
PROJECTS WHICH WOULD HELP
TRANSITION CALIFORNIA TO A
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE AND HELP
CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATE AND
FEDERAL THIRTY BY THIRTY WHAT.
POLICIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL TODAY SHERI
PEMBERTON CHIEF EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS LEGISLATIVE LIAISON FOR
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
I'M SURE THE. BRIEF REMARKS BY
THE SPONSOR OR WILL IT TO ONLY-
THE FISCAL AND- YOU MAY.
MISPERTON. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS SHERI
PEMBERTON ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THE BILL
WILL JUST GIVE UP MORE TOOLS TO
BETTER MANAGE THESE LANDS THAT
WE CAN GENERATE MORE REVENUE
FOR RETIRED TEACHERS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WITHOUT WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE IF ANYONE IS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN NINETY. IN MADISON
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTEEN NINETY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO COMMENT
IN THE QUEUE. WONDERFUL WE'LL
TAKE IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I
SEE NO COMMENT UP IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO COMMENT FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'LL TAKE
THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES. IT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. THANK YOU.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ANOTHER
NOW IT ALREADY GOT OUT OKAY
YOU'RE DONE THANK YOU THANKS
ALL RIGHT. MR BERMAN. MR BERMAN.
AB FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE ENJOY
THE DO PASS RECOMMENDATION EVEN
WITHOUT YOU HAVING ME TALKED
EVERY CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER
ABOUT THIS BILL. I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO AND A
SECOND BY MYSTERY OF US. YOU
MAY PROCEED MADAM CHAIR THIS
WANT TO START BY THANKING YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND WISDOM
AND UNDERSTANDING DURING THESE
THESE VERY BUSY TIMES. A. B.
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE IN STORES
THAT CALIFORNIA LAWS CONSISTENT
WITH THE SEVENTEENTH AMENDMENT
TO THE U. S. CONSTITUTION BY
PROVIDING FOR AN ELECTION TO BE
HELD TO FILL A VACANCY. IN
CALIFORNIA'S REPRESENTATION IN
THE U. S. SENATE. EVEN IF THE
VACANCY OCCURS DURING THE LAST
TWO YEARS OF THE U. S. SENATE
TERM. AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT. BECAUSE THIS BILL SIMPLY
BRING STATE LAW TO COMPLIANCE
WITH THE U. S. CONSTITUTIONIT
HAS NO ADDITIONAL STATE OR
LOCAL COSTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR- BENEVOLENCE. AND AN
AYE VOTE I TAKE THAT MY
COMMENTS WOULD HAVE ACTUALLY
BEEN APPROPRIATE PERHAPS FOR
THE U. S. SENATOR COMING. THIS
BILL. BUT I ENJOYED MY
DISCUSSIONS WITH HIM THIS
MORNING ON OTHER BILLS. LOTS OF
INTERESTS YES MA'AM I SEE NO
COMMENTS IN THE GALLERY ON THIS
BILL WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
YOU HAVE NO WITNESS BUT ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NINE SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF F DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
WONDERFUL MR BERMAN I'LL TAKE
THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES. IF NOBODY
HAS ANY QUESTIONS AT THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH MR
FONG NOT VOTING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR GRACIOUSNESS. THANK YOU.
MR LEAD AB THREE. THIRTY NINE
ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO SECOND BY DR
COURT YOU MAY PLEASE TAKE
MEASURE MEMBERS TODAY IN
PRESENTING AB THREE THREE NINE
A BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE IN
CITY COUNCIL OR COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS MEETINGS EITHER IN
PERSON TELEPHONICALLY OR
THROUGH THE INTERNET THE BILL
AS A NON REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE AND COSTS TO THE STATE
WILL BE NEGLIGIBLE STRICTLY
ASTER I VOTE AND I HAVE KILLING
THE INFORMATIONAL YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION SPEAKING
SUPPORT TODAY. I THINK IT WILL
TAKE IT TO THE WITNESS ON THE
PHONE LINE. MISTY IN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS CAITLYN
BEING ON BEHALF OF A STILL YEAR
CALIFORNIA ACTION WE ARE CO
SPONSORING THE BILL EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY NINE IS A NON
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE AND
HAVE NEGLIGIBLE CALL TO THE
STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU. WILL NOW GO T
PHONE LINES ANYBODY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO AB THREE THREE
NINE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE THREE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WOULD BE JUST A
MOMENT FIRST TOGETHER THE LINE
NUMBERS. NINE ONE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SCOTT KAUFMAN HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS A LIVIA SIDED
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COSPONSORED THREE THREE NINE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SORRY ON MUTE
JENNIFER KENNEDY L. A. COUNTY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS BEGAN MERRIER
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN OPPOSITION. NINE ONE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I TRY TO
REMEMBER CALLING ON BEHALF OF
OAKLAND PRIVACY IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE THREE NINE. AND ONE
MOMENT. NINE ONE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE OF. ONE HI. HELLO
YES YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
APOLOGIES- PARTICULAR ON BEHALF
OF OUR PRISON PUBLIC
RECOMMENDATIONS AND SOLUTIONS
IN MANAGEMENT IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU AS
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I SEE NO COMMENTS I DON'T
BELIEVE I SEE ANYONE ARE THERE
IS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A-
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AT THE
MICROPHONE. JUST YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTS A
PROPOSED THANK YOU.
GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS RUSSELL KAY YOUNG
YOUNG LEGISLATIVE AIDE TO
DEVELOP A BECCLES AND- ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FOURTEEN DELEGATES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS
SEEING NONE MR LEE- THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH MR
DAVIES MR FONG NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT MISS
FRIEDMAN LOOKS LIKE YOUR NEXT
YOU HAVE TO BILLS UP. LET'S
START WITH AB FOURTEEN- WANTED
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LED BY
MYSTERY ON A SECOND BY DOCTOR
CORK THANK OU THE COST OF THIS
BILL ARE MINOR AND OBSERVABLE
THIS BILL HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH THE COMMITTEES
THAT IT WENT THROUGH- THIS BILL
PROHIBITS A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FROM IMPOSING ON FORCING A
PARKING AT MINIMUM REQUIREMENT
ON DEVELOPERS NEAR PUBLIC
TRANSIT. IT DOES NOT PROHIBIT
PROPERTY OWNERS FROM BUILDING
ON SITE PARKING RATHER IT
ALLOWS THE DEVELOPER THE OWNER
OF THE PROPERTY TO RIGHT SIZE
THE PARKING FOR THEIR
PARTICULAR DEVELOPMENT THIS
WILL HELP LOWER THE COST OF
BUILDING HOUSING LEAD TO BETTER
LAND USE AND AYE. URGENT AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. I HAVE NO
WITNESSES LISTED WITH THAT
WE'LL GO TO SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. OF AB FORTINO ONE
TO THE PHONES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB FORTINO ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. LINE ONE FORTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FORTY FOUR
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE. AND MOVING
ON TO LINE EIGHTY FOUR LINE
EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. VACANCY ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER MOM
POVERTY AND THE CALIFORNIA BURL
LEGALISTIC FOUNDATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
MATHEMATICS THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNINGJOSE
TRINIDAD CASTANEDA ON BEHALF OF
THE BY THE HOUSING LOS ANGELES
AND STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
SEVENTY THREE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIKE
SEVENTY THREE YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND LIVING ON MINE.
NINETY FIVE NINE NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JUSTIN
HIGHER FROM THE SLOCAN VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR NUMBER-
WILLIAMSBURG ON THE BALLING-
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA YIMBY- THE SAN
FRANCISCO PLANNING AND URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION ACCOUNT
OPEN TILL BUILDERS THANK YOU TO
COALITION HAVE AFFECTED
HUMANITY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION GREENBELT ALLIANCE
AND KILLED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY FOUR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE MY SIXTY FOUR YEAR OLD
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AMIR KHAN-
WITH THE HELP OF AN OLDER
CONFINEMENT SUPPORT AS WELL AS
WITH RELATED CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING KAREN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CARTER
RIBBONED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
EXPRESSING OUR STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO EVERYONE WAS HERIS
ROSENBLOOM BUT THE LOS ANGELES
BUSINESS COUNCIL CALLING ITSELF
THE POOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING- CHERRY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ADAM JEFF SICK WITH THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WARRANTED PLENTY OF
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN PRIDE
IN ASSOCIATION WITH THE SUPPORT
OF THE MEDITATION THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YU-
WITHOUT WE WILL. OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOMEBODY IN THE
GALLERY TO SPEAK. I SEE NOBODY
GETTING UP FOR THIS BILL. BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE
NO COMMENTS. THREE MEN WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSER TO TAKE THAT AS
YOUR CLOTHES YES MY CLOTHES.
THANK YOU FELT ON A B. ROLL
CALL WITH MR FONG VOTING HIGH
AND MR LEVINE VOTING NOW. ALL
RIGHT MOVING ON TO AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY SIX MISS FRIEDMAN IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
I HAVE A MOTION BY MISTAKE THE
SECOND PREMISE CARILLO. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU A TERRORIST
THIS BILL HAS NEGLIGIBLE COSTS
AND IS A CONSUMER PROTECTION
MEASURE CALIFORNIA LAW
CURRENTLY STATES THAT A TICKET
BUYER TO A LIVE EVENT MIGHT
REQUEST A REFUND WHEN AVENTIS
CANCEL POSTPONE A RESCHEDULE.
HOWEVER DOES NOT STATE WHEN THE
CUSTOMER SHOULD RECEIVE THEIR
MONEY BACK FOR THE TICKET
SELLER. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX
THAT'S CLEAR DEADLINES FOR
TICKET SELLERS TO REFUND TICKET
BUYERS IT REQUIRES OF THE
TICKET BUYER FOR POSTPONED OR
RESCHEDULED EVENT REFUND WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS OF CANCELLATION
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF A
REQUEST. THE TICKET PRICE FOR
THE COUNCIL EVENT. IN ADDITION
IT REQUIRES A SELLER- IN A
TICKET SELLER DISCLOSED TO THE
BUYER WHETHER OR NOT A TICKET
IS TRANSFERABLE TO A THIRD
PARTY. WITH THIS I REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AS WE I DO NOT SEE ANY
WITNESSES LISTED FOR YOU SO
WE'LL JUST GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB. FIFTEEN FIFTY
SIX. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. NINE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TIM LYNCH ON BEHALF
OF THE AMBASSADOR THEATRE GROUP
BASED OUT OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
WE HAVE- APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WORK OUT WE HAVE ONE
REMAINING POLICY AND SERVE
WHAT'S OF THE BILL THANK YOUNG.
THAT NGUYEN SQUEAK BY THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT TAKING
BACK I SEEN NO QUESTIONS.
FAILING AT MY JOB TODAY. MS
FRIEDMAN- I TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES IT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU. DR
QUIRK. LET'S START WITH YOU
HAVE TO BILLS- WE'LL START WITH
AB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN IT ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I SEE
A MOTION BY MISS CARILLO SECOND
BY MISS CALLED AROUND. ARMOS
DAVIES. I APPRECIATE ALL THE
WOMEN IN THIS ROW HELPING ME
OUT TODAY- YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FIVE THREE SEVEN.
MODIFIES THE STATE BROADBAND
PERMITTING PROCESS TO ENSURE
LINES WITH UPDATED FEDERAL
RULES. IT ALSO PROVIDES CLARITY
AROUND THE STARTING POINT FOR
THE SHOT CLOCK AS WELL AS
CLARITY FOR THE EXISTING GAVE
TO PROVE PROCESS AT THE
CONCLUSION THE START AT THE
SHOT CLOCK. AS THE ANALYSIS ARE
HIGHLIGHTS THIS BILL DOES NOT
HAVE STATE CROSS BECAUSE LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
LEVEL FEES AND CHARGES TO COVER
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BILL- THE- IN THE FUTURE WE ARE
WORKING VERY HARD WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO COME UP WITH
LANGUAGE WE CAN ALL AGREE ON I
THINK WE'RE TRYING TO GO IN THE
SAME DIRECTION- BUT IT'S IN THE
HANDS OF THE LAWYERS- HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN THIS NAY TO SELL
OFF. ON BEHALF OF CROWN CASTLE
WILL SPEAK BRIEFLY ON THE- OF
FINANCIAL ASPECTS OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES- THE DANCE RIGHT SIR.
MAKES ALL OF ON BEHALF OF DAN
SCHNEIDER IN THE CROWN CASTLE
SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS OF THE
BILL WE AGREE WITH THE
COMMITTEES FISCAL ANALYSIS THIS
BILL WILL NOT CUT THE STATE ANY
MONEY SINCE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
CAN CHARGE FEES TO COVER
PERMITTING COSTS. THE BILL WILL
ALLOW HIGH SPEED INTERNET
PROJECTS TO BE BUILT IN MONTHS
INSTEAD OF YEARS. AND THE BILL
ALSO ALLOWS- BUT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO RETAIN LOCAL
CONTROL COULD SIMPLY ALLOW THEM
TO APPROVE OR DENY PERMITS IT
JUST MANDATES THAT THEY DO IT
AND THE FEDERALLY MANDATED
TIMELINES WHEN YOU RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE ALSO HAVE AN
OPPOSITION- WITNESS LISTED ARE
PROPER AND DODD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR NURSES
FOR A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT.
CATHERINE ARE YOU ON THE LINE
MORNING TURNS OUT THANK NIGHT I
AM. GOOD MORNING SURE GONZALEZ
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS KATHERINE DOBSON THE
ALLIANCE AND NURSES FOR HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT. FOR MANY REASONS
TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT THIS BILL
INCLUDING YOU SUPPORT
USURPATION OF LOCAL CONTROL BY
FURTHER TIGHTENING LOCAL
DECISION MAKING TIMELINE A. K.
H. SHOT CLOCKS PROMOTE AND
COMPOSED DEEMED APPROVAL
STANDARDS WHICH THE FCC REFUSED
TO ADOPT AND THE NINTH CIRCUIT
COURT OF APPEALS REFUSED TO
GRANT IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY. BEYOND HEALTH AND
SAFETY CONCERNS BUT WE FOCUS ON
THE FISCAL IMPACT OF ALL
FOLLOWED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
FIFTIES RICHARD HEARD ABOUT ARE
LIMITED BY LAW. THEY PROTECT
THE COST PER TEAM TO THE
LITIGATION LIABILITY COSTS
FIRST OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FAILED TO MEET TO SHORTEN
DEEMED APPROVAL SHOT CLOCK.
THIS BILL REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PAY FOR THE
COURT CHALLENGES TO TELECOM
APPLICANTS INSTEAD OF THE OTHER
WAY AROUND THIS IS THE
OPPOSITION. THE OPPOSITE
POSITION AT THE FCC RULES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS THIS TRANSFER
OF LITIGATION COSTS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ALMOST CERTAINLY BE.
A FINANCIAL BURDEN THERE'S ALSO
THE LACK OF LIABILITY INSURANCE
FOR WIRELESS BROADBAND
PROVIDERS WHICH TRANSFERS
CONSUL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
COMMUNITIES. THE TELECOM
RELATED MALIBU FIRE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN COST SIX BILLION
DOLLARS AND BURNED OVER A
THOUSAND ACRES COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT FIRE NOT INCLUDING
THE HEALTH COSTS WERE BORNE BY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND ARE IN
PART BY CITIES LIKE MALIBU AND
MANY OTHERS ACROSS THE STATE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. AND
TO SB FIVE FIVE SIX. THURMOND
BILLS TO SET. THAT PROMOTES.
FAST IN X. AND HIGH AFFECT WIRE
BROAD TO HOMES AND- ACROSS.
WHILE IT'S BROADBAND TECHNOLOGY
IS NOT THE SAME THING AND DID
NOT CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
INTO THESE WHO CANNOT AFFORD
WIRELESS TECHNOLOGY. THIS IS
NOT A SOLUTION TO PROVIDE
EQUITY AND TO CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY WE
URGE YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE'VE HAD-
TWO MINUTES OF TEST ME IN
SUPPORT IN TWO MINUTES IN
OPPOSITION WE WILL. FIRST TAKE
IT TO THE GALLERY IF THERE'S
SOMEBODY HERE WHO WANTS TO
REGISTER OR AT THE POINT WHERE
YOU JUST REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME THE ORGANIZATION. AND YOUR
POSITION. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
JOHANNA FINNEY REPRESENTING ALL
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPALITIES WHO
ALREADY HAVE FILIAL COMPLYING
TELECOM OR DETAILS. IN THIS
COMMITTEE WE AND WE OPPOSE THAT
IS MY GROUP'S NAME AND WE
OPPOSE OKAY THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS PAUL MAKE GAVIN FROM WIRE
CALIFORNIA AND I'M ALSO WITH
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE BEFUDDLED
THAT TWELVE BILLS HAVE SPEAKERSTODAY THE OTHER HUNDRED NINE
AND WE AN'T GET IN TOUCH WITH
THE COMMITTEE THEY WON'T RETURN
A CALL WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU FOR REGISTERING
OPPOSITION. SEE NO MORE PEOPLE
COMING TO THE MARKET WE HAVE A
WE DO HAVE A I'M SORRY. ONE
MORE AT THE MICROPHONE. MORNING
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS MARK
GRAHAM ON BEHALF OF PRESERVED
THE LOCAL AUTHORITY OF CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO REGULATE THE
PLACEMENT OF CELL ANTENNAS. AND
WE OPPOSE. THANK YOU. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE LINES
ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
AB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN AGAIN-
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
HARD TO HEAR PLEASE AS- DON'T
GET TOO CREATIVE ON THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT- WE
ARE ONLY LOOKING FOR A NAME. IF
YOU BELONG TO AN ORGANIZATION
SUPPORTER OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF A. B. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JUST
MARKLEEVILLE COME BY WE'RE SHIP
GROUP OR YOU ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT AB FIVE TO SEVEN THANK
YOU. AND. NINE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
NUMBERS ROXANE GOLDBERG ANY
WIRELESS INFRASTRUCTURE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
WROTE ON BEHALF OF T. MOBILE
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
SYDNEY **** I REPRESENT SAFETY
CHECK FOR SANTA ROSA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIVE THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOUNG.
NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY ELAINE
WOULD BE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE SEVENTY NINE YOU
MAY BE ON ME PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OF. ONE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS KATHLEEN
GUILTY ON BEHALF OF BY G. THREE
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. NINE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PARABELLUM
BEHALF OF THE TI EIGHTY TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MELANIE FIGUEROA OUT
BEHALF OF VERIZON IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANIEL GOOD CARRIED ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES THIS IS. TERRY ALLEN OFF I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY EIGHTY
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
HUNDRED AND ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE MOMENT PLEASE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER KENNEDY
L. A. COUNTY I OPPOSE. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
WILL BRING THAT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SEEN NO QUESTIONS ARE
DOCTOR PARK THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MR BIGELOW NOT
VOTING THANK YOU. YOU CAN NOW
TAKE YOUR SECOND BILL AB
THIRTEEN OH TWO UP IT IS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION OUR MOTION
BY MISS CALDERON A SECOND BY
MISS DAVIES YOU MAY PROCEED.
OKAY GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AGAIN I AB THIRTEEN
OH TWO CODIFIES REGULATIONS THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
ADOPTED IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
REGARDING CANNABIS BILLBOARD
ADVERTISEMENTS ALONG HIGHWAYS-
IT BECAUSE THERE'S SOME
AMBIGUITY IN THE LANGUAGE OUR
FOR THE PROPOSITION- IT WAS
OVERTURNED BY A COURT DECISION-
I WILL NOTE THAT THE COSTS ARE
MINOR AND OBSERVABLE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ARRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
LISTED- ON THE PHONES HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL HAVE VERY. MINOR
COMMENTS ABOUT THE FISCAL ON
THIS BILL. YES THANK YOU MEGAN
WEBER. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MAKE A LOAF ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU AND AMY
JENKINS. YES GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AMY JENKINS
WITH PRECISION ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
ALSO AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. WONDERFUL
THANK YOU- GREAT WITNESSES WILL
MOVE ON TO THE- PHONE LINES- IS
THERE SOMEBODY IN THE GALLERY
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON AB
THIRTEEN OH TWO IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB. THIRTEEN OH
TWO. LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE SOME
FOLKS. HI MY NAME IS PAUL
MCGANN FROM CALIFORNIANS WHO
OPPOSE PORK BARREL TELECOM
BILLS BY CENTER TO KIRK AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
THIS BILL HAS TO HAVE CANNABIS
ADVERTISING BUT I APPRECIATE
THE- ATTEMPT. MMHM MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MARK GRAHAM
ON BEHALF OF KEEP CELL ANTENNAS
AWAY FROM HOMES AND SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. SOUNDS LIKE A MULTI
FACETED A ORGANIZATION WILL GO
TO- WE GOT ONE MORE. YOU KNOW
THERE'S SO MUCH INTEREST IN
CANNABIS ADVERTISING. HI MY
NAME IS JOHANNA FINNEY FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR WIRED FIBER
OPTICS FOR EVERYONE WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU WITH THAT
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB.
THIRTEEN OH TWO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTEEN OH TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF CMG KHALIFA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN OH TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE ONE
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SENATE CHAIR
ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF EASY
AND KIVA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN OH TWO. THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS MADELINE
COOPER ON BEHALF OF- CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PROBABLY
NOT. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE
ONE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING I
CAN I CAN CONFIRM BEHALF OF CAL
MORE MALL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE OH ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER KENNEDY
L. A. COUNTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. ONE ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MANAGER NEAR ME. YES I CAN'T
SIGN. GOOD MORNING WITH SUCH
ASSEMBLY MAPS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS INTO AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU- WHAT THAT
WILL BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AB THIRTEEN OH TWO
LOOKS LIKE EVERYBODY'S. OKAY
WITH THAT MISTER CORTEX OUT
NETWORK THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU. WITH
MR CHOW NOT VOTING. THANK YOU
AT THIS POINT WILL READ THE
BILLS- THAT HAVE BEEN MOVED TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MISTER
CONSULTANT. YOUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT. SB SIX THIRTY ONE
BLOOM AB TWELVE NINETY EIGHT
BELOW MAY BE THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO
CARILLO AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN CERVANTES AB TWELVE
TWENTY ONE FLOOR AB TEN SIXTY
FOUR FONG AB ELEVEN FIFTY
FRAZIER AB THIRTY SIX GALLAGHER
AB FIFTY GALLAGHER AB TEN
THIRTY SEVEN GRAYSON AB TWELVE
SEVENTY FIVE JONES SAWYER AB
FIVE SEVEN ONE MAYES EVERY AB
ELEVEN NINETY MAYES A. B.
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE MURATSUCHI
AB SEVEN FIVE EIGHT NAZARIAN AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO OR DONALD A
B. AJ ARE SEVEN PATTERSON. AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT QUIRK AB
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE SALAS AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE- COMMITTEE ON
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY SIX COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN COMEDIAN
OR GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION AB. FIFTEEN EIGHTY
NINE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU I'LL
TAKE A MOTION FOR MISTER
BIGELOW IN A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO. ON THE KENTUCKY AND I
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AT
THIS TIME WE WILL READ- THE
REST OF THE BILLS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN PRESENTED ON THAT WILL BE
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
WHICH WILL BE. DISPENSED OF
TOMORROW. SB SIX SIX ONE VENICE
AB THREE SEVEN BERMAN AB SEVEN
NINE SIX BERMAN AB SEVENTY ONE
BLOOM MAYBE ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
BALLOON MAYBE TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
BLOOM A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT BONTA AB TWELVE SEVEN SIX
CARILLO AB FIVE TWO FIVE CHU A.
B. FIVE FIFTY CHIU AB FOR NINE
FIFTEEN CHU AB NINE THREE FOUR
COOLEY AB FIVE SEVEN NINE FLOOR
AB TWO FONG. AB NINE SEVEN NINE
FRAZIER AB NINETY EIGHT ONE
FRAZIER AB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE
FRAZIER AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN
FRIEDMAN AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE
CRISTINA GARCIA A. B. S. AB
SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT EDUARDO
GARCIA AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED WATER
GARCIA AB TWO FIVE SEVEN LORENA
GONZALEZ EIGHTY SEVEN A ONE
LEARNING GONZALEZ AT ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE LEARNING IT'S ALL
AS AB THIRTEEN NINETEEN THE ANA
GONZALEZ AB SEVEN FIVE THREE
GRAYSON AT ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE
GRAYSON. AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
NINE HOLDEN AB FIVE ONE NINE
IRWIN AB FOUR ONE SIX KALRA AB
THREE SIX NINE COMMA EAGER AB
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT LEVINE AB
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR LOW AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT LOW AB
FIVE FOUR FIVE NINE MATHIS AB
NINE TWO SIX MATHIS AB FOUR
FOUR SIX MAYES AB SEVEN FIVE
NINE MCCARTY EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN MCCARTY AB SEVENTY WAIT
MULLIN AT ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
MULLIN AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE
ARTS SUSHI. AB FIVE TWO THREE
MISSOURI IN AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN
O'DONNELL EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
PETRIE-NORRIS AB FIVE FOUR FIVE
QUIRKY THREE SIX TWO QUICK
SILVA AB EIGHT SIX FIVE QUICK
SILVA AB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE
RAMOS EIGHTY FOUR ONE TWO RAY
IS AB NINE EIGHT FOUR
THREE OF US AB THREE SEVEN
SEVEN ROBERT RIVAS AB FIVE SIX
EIGHT ROBERT RIVAS AB ONE ONE
ONE ZERO ROBERT RIVAS AB EIGHT
TO RODRIGUEZ. AB EIGHT SEVEN
NINE BLANCA BLANCA RUBIO EIGHTY
ONE THREE SIX ONE BLANCA RUBIO
AB THREE THREE SALAS AB SIX
NINE NINE SALAS AB FIFTEEN OH
THREE SANTIAGO AB FOUR SEVEN
EIGHTEEN AB TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHTEEN AB EIGHT SEVEN FIVE
WOULD IT BE NINE FOR TWO WOULD
AB ELEVEN THIRTY TWO WHAT. AB
ELEVEN OR THIRTEEN A LOT IN
WOOD. A. B. SEVEN ONE NINE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS. AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE MEDIA
BUSINESS A PROFESSION AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS. THAT
COMPLETES ALL OF THE BILLS
THERE NOW BEEN MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. WE'VE DONE THAT
EVERY WEEK AND THAT FILE WILL
BE DISPENSED OF TOMORROW IF YOU
ARE- HOPING TO EXPRESS YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO ONE OF
THE BILLS THAT WAS NAMED JUST
NOW- WHERE THE AUTHOR HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION SO THERE IS
NO PRESENTATION ON THE BILL BUT
YOU STILL WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. FOR
ANY BILL- YOU MAY DO SO NOW
THIS IS PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
START WITH FOLKS IN THE GALLERY
AND- BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
PEOPLE WAITING ON THE LINES AND
IN THE GALLERY I. EXPECT ONE
ORGANIZATION PER PERSON AND-
OF. VERY QUICK SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME'S JONATHAN BARRACLOUGH IF-
I AM A NASA ENGINEER AND- AN
AIR FORCE VETERAN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS JOHANNA FINNEY I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST AGAINST
THIS DISPOSAL OF DEMOCRATIC
TRANSPARENCY ON ALL OF THESE
BILLS TODAY WE PUT OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. I'M SORRY JUST POINT
OF ORDER IS A COMMENT FOR ALL
THE BILLS YOU JUST READ OR JUST
FOR EACHINDIVIDUAL BILL WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH TO ME NOW.
DO WE HAVE AN ADDRESS PRESS
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR
WHICH ONE. FOR THE BILLS THAT
HAVE BEEN MOVED TO SUSPENSE
EVERY SINGLE ONE. HOW MANY DID
YOU READ LIKE FIFTY. YOU WANT
ME TO HAVE ONE COMMENT OF
SUPPORT OR- OPPOSITION FOR ALL
FIFTY BILLS AT THIS TIME.
ABSOLUTELY YOU CAN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE ANY INDIVIDUAL LIKE
INDIVIDUALLY OKAY HOSE ALL
FIFTEEN BILLS IN ONE COMMENT
THOSE ARE THE RULES THAT ARE
I'M GONNA GO THROUGH
INDIVIDUALLY AND I DON'T
REMEMBER THE NUMBERS I'M GONNA
GO THROUGH THEM ONE AT A TIME
SIR OKAY- DOES NOT. YOU ARE
GOING TO ABIDE BY THE RULES OF
THIS COMMITTEE YOU MAY IF YOU
KNOW A BILL THAT YOU ARE
SUPPORTED OR OPPOSED TO YOU
KNOW THE BILL NUMBER YOU CAN
READ IT NOW OKAY ONE SECOND OR
YOU CAN LEAVE THE ON GOING TO
MY LIST I'M GOING RIGHT NOW TO
FIND THANK YOU. AND NOW THAT
I'M CLEAR I'LL GET MY LIST
PLEASE WAIT FOR ME. NO WE ARE
NOT WAY MORE MOVING ON WE HAVE
A HUNDRED FOR BILLS WE CAN MOVE
ON. THEY HAVE A HUNDRED NINE
BILLS WHICH YOU HAVE TWELVE.
TEACHERS THAT'S CORRECT PLEASE
REMOVE. THE GENTLEMAN FROM THE
BUILDING. WE HAVE VERY CLEAR
RULES IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
WE'RE GOING TO BUY BY THEM YOU
CAN READ A BILL YOU ARE OPPOSED
TO. ANY BILL YOU'RE OPPOSED TO.
BUT THAT ISN'T. MORNING MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS- OF MARK GRAHAM
AND SPEAKING ADDRESSING ON A.
B. FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AS
PRIMARILY A FINANCIAL OR COST
ISSUE NOT A TECHNOLOGICAL ISSUE
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT I'M SEE NOBODY
ELSE COMING TO THE MICROPHONE
THERE'S TWO MORE PEOPLE I'M
SORRY I CAN'T SEE BEHIND THE
CHANDELIER. HELLO I'M IN THE
ABSENT PARENT LEADER IN THE NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOL
COMMUNITY ON BEHALF OFHUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES WE
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ROUGH OKAY YOUNG
YOUNG HOLDING AB ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WITHOUT WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO
TO OUR PHONE LINES IF ANYBODY
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO ANY OF
THE BILLS THAT WERE MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE YOU MAY DO SO
NOW. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF ANY OF THE
BILLS MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST.
CALLER IS MINE ONE THIRTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING-
OUT OF CHAIR MEMBERS COMMITTEE
CAPPING LUNCH REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN FOREST AND PAPER
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION SB
SIX SIX ONE. AND ALSO
REGISTERING OPPOSITION AB FOUR
ONE SIX ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FOREST AND PAPER
ASSOCIATION THE WESTERN WENT
PRESERVERS INSTITUTE AND THE
AMERICAN WHAT COUNCIL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE
TODAY. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ADAM CHAIR
TONY TO GUERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
SEVEN WE'RE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THREE THREE NINE THAT PASSED
EARLIER JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THE COMMITTEE WAS AWARE OF
THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRED
MEMBERS ON THAT FROM US ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC ADVOCATES- WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN TWENTY ONE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE SEVENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
FOLLOWING MEASURES AB THREE SIX
NINE KAM LAGER AB FIVE TWO
THREE UNITARIANS AB FIVE FOUR
ZERO PETRIE NORRIS EIGHTY SEVEN
NINE SIX BERMAN EIGHTY NINE
FOUR TWO WOULD IN AB TWELVE
THIRTY EIGHT TANG. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JOHN THE CHAIR AND DIRECTOR FOR
VALLEY VIEW CHARTER CRAP I
STAND FOR ALL STUDENTS IN
OPPOSITION. AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN
OF DONALD. THANK YOU I WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS IT'S JUST
SUPPORTER POSE IN WHO YOU
REPRESENT WHAT. THEY HAVE A LOT
OF BILLS. NINE ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE FIFTY YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE ALL OF THE HELLO THIS IS
CHRIS MCCARRON GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I AM
THE FOUNDER MERISTEM ACADEMY IN
THE EXECUTOR RECTOR OF CORE
CHARTER SCHOOL AND ON BEHALF OF
THESE PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS I
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU. MY NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JUSTIN HARTLEY THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
WE HAVE A SUPPORT POSITION ON
AB NINETY FOUR AND A SUPPORT OF
AMENDED POSITION ON AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAMBERS
THAT NOW THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS WILLIAM MICHAEL
BURKE ON BEHALF- THE FOLLOWING
CLIENTS AND BILLS ARE STARTING
WITH- AB THREE THREE NINE WHICH
WITH THAT PASSED EARLIER
CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN SUPPORT
AFTER THE SUCCESS OF THE
SUSPENSE FILE. EIGHTY FIVE
NINETEEN- CALIFORNIA BEEKEEPERS
AS SPONSORS- AB SEVEN NINETEEN
ALSO SPONSORS CALIFORNIA
BEEKEEPERS ASSOCIATION EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY THREE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY IN SUPPORT. AND EIGHTY
NINE FIFTEEN I LIKE LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL SUPPORT IN EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED THE TREE CARE INDUSTRY
THAT THE NATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MANY MCCARTY VOCAL REPRESENTING
LOBBY HELP AND ARE FOR PEACE
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA CALLING
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY FIVE TWO THREE AND
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH NAY IN
MARIN IS THE NAME. IT'S ASKING
HER IF HE'S CRAPPIE FIND ONE OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALL AND MOVING TO
NINE FORTY FOUR NINE FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DOESN'T WANT TO BE THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE THE SPONSOR
AND IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE RUBIO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIRPERSON
MY NAME IS JEAN BOARD HERE AND
I REPRESENT THE GOVERNMENT OF
CANADA. CANADA RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSES A. B. FOUR ONE SIX.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JASON
SOMEONE ON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROGRAM
SOLICITATION WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT SPONSOR ABC EIGHT SIX
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
ONE TEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JOSE TREND THAT CABINET ON
BEHALF OF CLIMATE ACTION
CAMPAIGN IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO EASY ELEVEN THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MOLLUSCUM ACQUIRE
CONCERNED PARENTS IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. THANK
YOU. ONE NINETY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT KATHY DEBT
HELLO WITH METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE. AND ON BEHALF OF
METROPOLITAN AND STATE WAER
CONTRACTORS WE OPPOSE AB NINE
SEVEN NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WARNING-
READ ANDERSON ALSO PENDING
UNION MEMBER I OPPOSE AB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MODERATOR MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS YOU COMMITTEE JEREMY
THAT YOU'RE A BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION EIGHTY THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE AND THE PORK OF
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS KARINA GONZALEZ AND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT EIGHTY
CALLING AND STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE THANK
YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI EDDIE ON A BRIGHT LINE
DEFENSE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
TWO FIVE CHU ON OFFSHORE WIND
THANK YOU. ONE ONE OH FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS AUDREY IVERSON FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I AM CLOSE
AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. THANK YOU.
ONE ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS RACHEL ALTSHULER I'M A
CHARTER SCHOOL EDUCATOR FROM
VENTURA COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME IS
BREANNA DELGADO ON THE
CALIFORNIA CREDENTIALED TEACHER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS JESSICA HALL I'M
CALLING IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE
THREE ONE SIX AM AS CHARTER
SCHOOL PARENTS THINK YOU THINK
YOU. MY ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHAT A LITTLE BIT GONZALEZ
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY SEVEN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE AND A. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JEFF RICE ON BEHALF OF
THE EIGHT PLUS PERSONALIZED
LEARNING NETWORK ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. ONE ONE SIXTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS SERRA
GRECO I'M A CHARTER SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE AND I OPPOSE AB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. THANK YOU. MY
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
DIANE WALKIE ON BEHALF OF STATE
HEALTHY PLAYING FIELD WE
OPPOSE. SB. SIX SIX ONE. NINE
ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JENNIFER
KENNEDY IN L. A. COUNTY-
REDUCING OPPOSITION. FOR THIRTY
SEVEN TO FIFTY SEVEN SEVEN
NINETY SIX FIFTEEN OH THREE AND
STRONG OPPOSITION FOR ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE AND THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN MY AND HER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU. NINE
ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ERIC HAGEN A PARENT AND
PRINCIPAL AT ENDEAVOR CHARTER
SCHOOL IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND
WESTERN SURE CHARTER SCHOOLS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR CAN DELFINO ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING CLIENTS
THE FALLEN BILLS- CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY AND
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE- SPEECH IN THE LAND TRUST
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED. DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
AND CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY IN A SUPPORT EVENT
DISPOSITION FOR EIGHTY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED AND FINALLY DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE AS A SPONSOR. AND
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
ONE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CHRISTOPH OF BELLMER PRESENTING
CALIFORNIA AND DEMOCRATS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY ONE THIRTY THREE
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING
ON TO LINE ONE AT ONE. LINE ONE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
THIS IS NICOLE ME BERMAN HOME
SCHOOL FAMILY NO VOEPEL SUCCESS
OF OVER THE YEARS HERE CALLING
IN TO OPPOSE AB. ONE THREE ONE
SIX THANKS AND HAVE A GREAT
DAY. THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS DEBORAH- ST I'M A
CREDENTIALED TEACHER HERE IN
LONG BEACH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. AB. THIRTEEN SIXTEEN.
NINE ONE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS PATRICK CALLS ON
BEHALF THE TRIMBLE I WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TEN THIRTY SEVEN AND DIGITAL
CONSTRUCTION TECHNOLOGIES. AND
ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS SHERRY
JOHNSON ASSISTANT DIRECTOR AND
CARING ABOUT HOME SCHOOLING
CHARTER I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. THANK YOU. ON
ONE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS DR
CAMPAIGN PEDIATRICIAN AND HOME
SCHOOLED HER PARENTS FROM SAN
MATEO COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSING
AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
ONE ONE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. RENDON TO
WORK ON BEHALF OF EMPLOYEES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I'M FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JOSEPH TAYLOR CALLED INTO WORK
OUR LOCAL IBEW CONTRACTOR IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BOB MORALIS WOULD
LEARN FOR LIFE REPRESENTING
EIGHTY LEARNING CENTERS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU. AND ONE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BRIAN I REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF
CHARTER SCHOOL FAMILIES IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN AND WOULD LIKE
TO REMIND YOU THAT YOU WORK FOR
THE TAXPAYERS NOT FOR TEACHERS.
OR THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE OH EIGHT YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
MOVING ON TO MINE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIVE. MY TWO OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS ANNA NET AND I WENT
HOME AND HYBRID EDUCATION AND
AYE OPPOSED H. E. TWO FIFTY
EIGHT PM THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS KAREN SERVICE I AM A
RESIDENT OF AMPLE COUNTY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY ONE
AND A ROOFTOP SOLAR OWNER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE ONE
THREE NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOUNG. AND ONE NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SH YES MY NAME IS NICOLE
JOHN I'M A LONG TIME HOME
SCHOOL CHARTER PARENTAGE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. NINE ONE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE. HELLO MY NAME IS NICK
SECOND ON BEHALF OF LIKE THE
ACADEMY CHARTER SCHOOL OPPOSING.
EIGHTY THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. NINE
TO ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
THREE TIMES I AM NOT- I HAVE A
SPECIAL NEED HOME STUDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. TWO THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD HELLO THANK YOU MY NAME
IS ERIN SHARPER- I LIVE IN
DISTRICT TWENTY ONE I AM A HOME
SCHOOL PARENT OF TWO SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS- USING A NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. THAT
CONVENTION WE DID HAVE TWO
PEOPLE JUST QUEUE UP OKAY. OKAY
MY ONE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE OPEN
GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN- THANK
YOU I DID GET A NUMBER. I AM
ALICE PROGRAM WITH I RETURN
SCHOOLS I AM THOSE AT A CLOSE
AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SEVEN FIVE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALL RIGHT HI THIS IS CHELSEA
MANNING WITH HIM CLIMB
SOLUTIONS CALLING STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B. ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I LEFT
MINE IS MINE TO SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS MARIA RAPER I'M A
TEACHER AT IQ ACADEMY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND MY APOLOGIES WE DID HAVE
ONE MORE QUEUE UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE ONE NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS LAURA WARD
I'M IN SILVERADO CALIFORNIA AND
I'M A HOMESCHOOL PARENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. ONE THREE
ONE SIX. AND WE DO HAVE TO
FURTHER CALLERS IN THE QUEUE
OKAY. ONE ONE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KAYLA AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN DIEGO GREEN NEW DEAL
ALLIANCE AND ITS SIXTY PLUS
MEMBERS OF NONPROFIT UNIONS AND
LOCAL BUSINESSES THE STRONGLY
OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL. CLINTON
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU. AND TWO
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GEN MAGAZINE
CALIFORNIA CREDENTIALED TEACHER
VENDOR FOR NON CLASSROOM BASED
AT CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND OPPOSED.
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. AND THERE ARE
TWO FURTHER COLORS. NINE TWO OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN OKAY. HI
MY NAME IS ASHLEY GLENN ON THE
PARENTS CREDENTIALED TEACHER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU. AND
TO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS SHOSHANA ALMOND AND I
AM A PARENT AND A TEACHER AT A
LANCASTER BASED CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. THANK YOU.
AND MINE TO TWENTY SIX. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD MY
NAME IS BETHANY CANTRELL AND I
AM FROM HANFORD CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. ONE THREE
ONE SIX. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE. NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
WHAT THAT THAT CONCLUDES. THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.